Just a quick one before we dive into today's episode. If you're in private practice, you might know the slightly awkward dance of actually getting paid. The I'll send you a bank transfer later that can often turn into sending chasing emails three weeks on. Well, this episode is brought to you by write-up. And their new tap to pay app might just sort that out for you. It turns your existing smartphone into a card reader. Your client finishes their session, taps their card, or. phone on yours, payment lands, receipt sent. No card machine to buy, no clunky terminal,
在进入今天的话题之前，先简单说几句。如果你从事私人执业，你可能了解在实际收款时那种略显尴尬的“舞蹈”。那种“我稍后给你转账”的话，往往会演变成三周后还在发邮件催款。好吧，本期节目由 Write-up 赞助。他们新推出的“点击支付”（tap to pay）应用程序或许能帮你解决这个问题。它能将你现有的智能手机变成读卡器。客户结束咨询后，只需用他们的卡或手机轻触你的手机，款项即刻到账，收据也会自动发送。无需购买刷卡机，没有笨重的终端，
no awkwardness. And because it's built into write-up, the payment links straight to the client's invoice and notes, so your admin actually stays joined up. Write-Up is the practice management platform built in the UK for UK practitioners. Have a look at write-up.com. That's W-R-I-T-E-U-P-P.com. Use code, marian, 30 for 30 days free and 30% off your first six months and see if it makes your week that little bit lighter with much better cash flow. So many people think their relationship problems started with dating but often the patterns were there long before that. The way you handle conflict, the people you feel drawn to, the way you shut down, overthink, over give or struggle to ask
没有尴尬。而且因为它内置于 Write-up 中，支付会直接关联到客户的发票和记录，让你的行政工作保持连贯。Write-up 是专为英国从业者打造的执业管理平台。请访问 write-up.com，即 W-R-I-T-E-U-P-P.com。使用优惠码 marian30，即可享受 30 天免费试用，并在前六个月获得 30% 的折扣，看看它是否能让你的工作周变得更轻松，现金流更顺畅。很多人认为他们的人际关系问题始于约会，但通常这些模式早在很久之前就已经存在了。你处理冲突的方式、你感到被吸引的人、你封闭自己、过度思考、过度付出或难以开口
for your needs to be met. A lot of it began in relationships that taught you what felt safe and what didn't. In this episode, fellow clinical psychologist Dr. Kate Sherrott and I explore relational patterns, burnout, dating, attachment, self-esteem and why we keep repeating dynamics that no longer serve us. Hi, welcome along to psychology actually. I am Dr. Marianne Trent, a qualified clinical psychologist and today I'm joined by Dr. Kate Sherritt, who is also a clinical psychologist. Hi Kate. Hello, great to be here, thanks. Thanks for being here. Today we're going to be thinking about relational patterns, how they show up for us, maybe why they show up, and a couple of kind of different examples of where they might show up. So before we go any further then,
表达需求的方式，很多都始于那些教会你什么是安全感、什么不是的关系。在本期节目中，临床心理学家凯特·谢罗特（Dr. Kate Sherrott）博士和我将探讨关系模式、倦怠、约会、依恋、自尊，以及为什么我们不断重复那些不再服务于我们的动力机制。嗨，欢迎来到《心理学实际上》（Psychology Actually）。我是玛丽安·特伦特（Dr. Marianne Trent）博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。今天和我一起的是同样身为临床心理学家的凯特·谢里特（Dr. Kate Sherritt）博士。嗨，凯特。你好，很高兴来到这里，谢谢。谢谢你的到来。今天我们将思考关系模式，它们如何在我们身上显现，为什么会显现，以及它们可能出现的几个不同例子。那么，在我们继续之前，
could you guide us through what is a relational pattern, Kate? Sure. So a relational pattern is a pattern of thinking, emotions and behaviour that develops, often quite early in our relationships with important people like our parents or other early caregivers, often it has a function to keep us safe and connected to them. And these patterns, I think the important thing to say is these patterns make huge amounts of sense
凯特，你能引导我们了解什么是关系模式吗？当然。关系模式是一种思维、情绪和行为的模式，通常在与父母或其他早期照料者等重要人物的早期关系中形成，它往往具有保持我们安全并与他们保持联系的功能。我认为重要的一点是，这些模式在它们形成的背景下是非常合理的，
in the context where they develop, but the problem is when people come to see me in adult life, confused about why they're doing something that doesn't make sense to them, or why they continually getting into the same situations, patterns that made sense originally can trip us up in everyday life when they jump contexts. Yeah, and I think clinically sometimes we might see
但问题在于，当人们在成年后来看我时，他们会困惑为什么自己会做一些在他们看来毫无意义的事情，或者为什么总是陷入同样的境地。原本合理的模式在跳出原有背景进入日常生活时，可能会让我们绊倒。是的，而且我认为在临床上，有时我们可能会看到
that when someone is struggling with something, maybe they isolate themselves, take themselves to a room to be by themselves, and then actually think, oh, this might be old. You know, I could probably speak to my partner or my children or a friend about the way I'm feeling. Maybe I don't need to do this, or maybe someone recognizes with them, you seem to always, you know, go to go to our room or go to your room when you are sad. And I wonder what that's about. So maybe they haven't noticed that themselves.
当某人正在为某事挣扎时，也许他们会孤立自己，躲进房间独处，然后实际上会想，哦，这可能是旧习惯。你知道，我其实可以和我的伴侣、孩子或朋友谈谈我的感受。也许我不需要这样做，或者也许有人认出了他们的行为：“你好像总是……你知道，当你难过时就去我们的房间或去你的房间。”我想知道这是怎么回事。所以也许他们自己还没有意识到这一点。
Are there any other examples, you know, that might help people to realize that some of their patterns might be older in style and maybe not serving them in the way they might hope they are still? Does that make sense, Kate? Yeah, I mean, I'm thinking of someone I was speaking to this week about workplace burnout. And there are so many diverse things under the hood when you look at burnout. But in this particular instance, we were talking about something that seems quite mundane. So there's overwork, there's being swamped at work and sort of being given loads of demands from people in meetings. But actually, for her, the flavour of the problem is that she was feeling very sort of, deflated, demoralised and resentful and like she wasn't being respected.
还有其他例子吗？你知道，这能帮助人们意识到他们的一些模式可能属于旧式风格，也许并没有像他们希望的那样服务于他们？这有意义吗，凯特？是的，我想到本周我和某人谈论职场倦怠。当你审视倦怠时，表面下有太多不同的东西。但在这种特殊情况下，我们谈论的是一些看起来很平凡的事情。比如过度工作、在工作中被淹没、在会议中被人们提出各种要求。但实际上，对她来说，问题的核心在于她感到非常沮丧、士气低落、充满怨恨，感觉自己没有受到尊重。
And actually it didn't add up from the details of the situation. And I think that's one key sort of little hair trigger of is this an old pattern? If the strength of feeling you've got in a situation doesn't quite add up, chances are there's another couple of layers underneath. And actually I said to her, sort of, I'm going to be a bit psychologisty here, just to ask you if I name this pattern in this way. So feeling like you can't speak up, feeling like your view isn't going to be heard and you'll be disrespected anyway, does that remind you of any time in your previous life?
实际上，从情况的细节来看，这并不完全吻合。我认为这是判断“这是否是一个旧模式”的一个关键触发点：如果你在某种情况下感受到的强烈程度与现实不符，那么很可能下面还有其他几层原因。实际上，我当时对她说，我得表现得有点“心理学家范儿”，问问你如果我这样命名这个模式：感觉自己无法说出想法，感觉自己的观点不会被倾听，无论如何都会被不尊重，这会让你想起以前生活中的任何时刻吗？
And she kind of sat there and went, yeah, yes, it does. And then we had a very fruitful conversation where we were able to link it to some earlier experiences with parents that made huge amounts of sense. And again, we're not talking. these experiences don't have to be, you know, abusive, vivid, kind of really, really obvious. Very well-intentioned parents with strong characters can just end up kind of giving you an M25 highway to a particular sort of expectation and response that you develop. There's fine in that relationship with them, but it's absolutely, you know, a route to burnout at work.
她坐在那里说，是的，确实如此。然后我们进行了一次非常有成效的对话，我们能够将其与早期与父母的一些经历联系起来，这非常有道理。再说一次，我们不是在谈论……这些经历不必是那种虐待性的、生动的、非常非常明显的。出发点很好的强势父母，最终可能会让你走上一条通往某种特定期望和反应的“M25高速公路”。在与他们的关系中这可能没问题，但这绝对是职场倦怠的途径。
So, yeah, does that answer your question? It really does. It's a lovely example. And what you've given us a really beautiful illustration of is is starting to piece together a formulation for this person. So why something emerged, what's keeping it maintained and trying to make sense of that. And it can just be this really illuminating a light bulb moment that helps people realise the very good and important reasons why this is likely still around for them, but just allows them to be. curious about whether this is something I need to hold on to, in which case that's a kind of functional way of behaving, or whether this might be old and whether this still fits. So
所以，这回答了你的问题吗？确实回答了。这是一个可爱的例子。你给我们提供了一个非常美丽的说明，即开始为这个人拼凑一个“构思”（formulation）：为什么某种东西会出现，是什么在维持它，并试图理解它。这可能是一个非常具有启发性的“顿悟时刻”，帮助人们意识到为什么这很可能仍然存在于他们身上，但同时也让他们能够好奇：这是否是我需要坚持的东西（在这种情况下，这是一种功能性的行为方式），还是这可能已经过时了，是否还适用。所以
I think what you're talking about is, yeah, is trying to formulate people so that they've got a user manual to their own brain. Is that right, Kate? A hundred percent. I absolutely love formulation. I think all of us sort of like particular elements of our craft. And for me, formulation is the, it's the one. And yes, I think what you say about context is important because once you're aware you've got choices and actually in the original context it still makes sense. I remember going to the Tavistock for training and attachment and it was so interesting. They were talking about child protection cases and once a child reaches a certain age where they've got the ability to sort of executive function and reason between different scenarios,
我认为你所说的是，是的，是试图为人们进行构思，让他们拥有自己大脑的“用户手册”。对吗，凯特？百分之百。我绝对热爱构思。我认为我们每个人都喜欢我们专业中的特定元素。对我来说，构思就是那个核心。是的，我认为你关于背景的说法很重要，因为一旦你意识到你有选择，而且实际上在最初的背景下它仍然是有意义的。我记得去塔维斯托克（Tavistock）接受依恋培训时，那非常有趣。他们谈论儿童保护案件，一旦孩子达到一定年龄，具备了执行功能并在不同情境之间进行推理的能力，
they were talking about how you might be able to help a child keep safe in one context by kind of encouraging some protective behaviours that they developed. But actually you could discuss with them sort of that that's not okay and that's not what we want for you and sort of with other adults and in other contexts you can behave differently. So you could see that even in a really, really challenging context at that age. But most of us, you know, don't have that external perspective that young. Yeah, but that kind of made me think that even, with parents who are still together and parents who aren't still together, you know,
他们谈论的是你如何能够通过鼓励他们发展出的一些保护性行为来帮助孩子在一种情境中保持安全。但实际上，你可以与他们讨论那是不对的，那不是我们想要的，在与其他成年人和其他情境中，你可以表现得不同。所以你可以看到，即使在那个年龄段，在非常非常具有挑战性的背景下也是如此。但我们大多数人，你知道，在那么小的时候并没有那种外部视角。是的，但这让我想起，即使对于仍然在一起的父母和不再在一起的父母，你知道，
a child will quickly learn what is okay with one parent and what is not okay with another. And, you know, individual differences, but also when it comes to, you know, maybe less than ideal parenting, then a child will have those benchmarks set. And that, can that play out in that child's friendship groups, in their kind of adult friendships as they grow up? Can it play out in their intimate relationships as they age? Oh, 100%. A different example of someone that originally came to me with burnout is really standing out to me because actually when we were discussing his lifestyle and his friendships and relationships, what was so striking is that the kind of protective pattern there was something
孩子会很快学会什么对一个父母是可以的，什么对另一个是不可以的。而且，你知道，存在个体差异，但当涉及到……你知道，也许不太理想的养育方式时，孩子就会设定那些基准。这会影响到那个孩子的友谊圈，影响到他们长大后的成人友谊吗？这会影响到他们随着年龄增长而建立的亲密关系吗？哦，百分之百。我最初因为倦怠来找我的一个人的例子非常突出，因为实际上当我们讨论他的生活方式、友谊和关系时，最引人注目的是那里的保护性模式是某种
I've kind of short-handed as a protector pattern, which is where actually it's safer for you to be self-reliant, independent and strong and sort of not rely on other people. But actually, that protective pattern made sense for him in his background, but meant that the burnout he was experiencing was because there was absolutely no social network around him at all. And he was really, really wanting a relationship. And particularly at work, sort of in a senior position, feeling very isolated. So yeah, absolutely, patterns that sort of develop in relationships when you're a child can sort of play out in some of the contexts that you choose and accept. So like a workplace context, which actually might also make it difficult for you to have a
我简称为“保护者模式”的东西，即实际上，保持自力更生、独立和坚强，不依赖他人对你来说更安全。但实际上，那种保护性模式在他的背景下是有意义的，但意味着他所经历的倦怠是因为他周围根本没有任何社交网络。他非常非常渴望一段关系。特别是在工作中，处于高级职位，感到非常孤立。所以是的，绝对，在童年时期在人际关系中形成的模式，可以体现在你选择和接受的一些情境中。比如职场环境，这实际上也可能使你难以拥有
social life. You might accept that more readily if you've got this protector pattern. And then you might respond differently in terms of reaching out to people or if people reach out to you as well. So it can become quite reciprocal as you get older if you don't notice and recognize your pattern, you can end up sort of further down a road where it becomes the natural way operate. Yeah, and I'm kind of thinking about, you know, people I've got to know across the years. And, you know, when, when you are in a work situation, especially if you're in a role where you're being clinically supervised, that can be kind of quite an intensive, at times emotionally intimate relationship, can't it? Which if someone's had a parenting experience of only ever getting
社交生活。如果你有这种保护者模式，你可能会更容易接受这一点。然后，在向他人伸出援手，或者如果别人向你伸出援手时，你的反应也会不同。所以随着年龄的增长，如果不能注意到并识别你的模式，它可能会变得相当相互作用，你最终可能会走上一条路，使它成为你自然的运作方式。是的，我正在思考，你知道，多年来我认识的人。而且，你知道，当你处于工作状态时，特别是如果你处于一个正在接受临床督导的角色中，那可能是一种相当深入的、有时在情感上很亲密的关系，不是吗？如果某人有过一种养育经历，即只有在惹麻烦或做错事时才能得到
attention from someone when they're in trouble or they've done something wrong and otherwise being left alone, then that kind of sense of being seen and having space held for you, well, that can be pretty discompobulating, can't it, Kate? Absolutely, yes. I mean, my prior background before private practice was working for a number of years in CBT and clinical psychology training, and we saw, Yes, the supervisory relationship in training, but I think also it can be in general, can bring up some of those kind of dynamics that you have with parents and caregivers. And absolutely some responses to supervision can be to sort of go, oh, why are you caring about me and asking these questions? Sort of leave me alone. And that's where it's a behaviour that can look the same on the outside, like not volunteering too much in supervision, can have lots of different underlying.
某人的关注，否则就会被冷落，那么那种被看见和被包容的感觉，嗯，可能会让人非常困惑，不是吗，凯特？绝对是，是的。我的意思是，在私人执业之前的背景是工作了几年，从事 CBT 和临床心理学培训，我们看到了，是的，培训中的督导关系，但我认为它也可以在一般情况下，引发一些你与父母和照料者之间的那种动力机制。而且绝对有一些对督导的反应可能是这样的：“哦，你为什么关心我并问这些问题？离我远点。”这就是那种在外部看起来一样的行为，比如在督导中不主动发言，可能有很多不同的潜在
reasons, one of which might be the protector pattern, sort of, oh, don't care about me, just let's keep this transactional. Or it could be a performer pattern where actually you're really worried about being found out, sort of you need to be seen as performing highly, you don't want to make any mistakes, you need to have your competence recognised. And so you might be withholding information or sort of feeling got out for a different reason, sort of are you trying to criticise me or tell me that I'm not good enough? Yeah, because criticism can be a really big one, can't it, like having things said to you about shaping, improving, reflecting, you know, that can, especially if you've kind of had issues of being criticised before or being humiliated or shamed,
原因，其中之一可能是保护者模式，比如，“别管我，让我们保持这种交易关系。”或者它可能是一种“表演者模式”，实际上你非常担心被发现，比如你需要被视为表现出色，你不想犯任何错误，你需要你的能力得到认可。所以你可能会隐瞒信息，或者因为不同的原因感到被针对，比如“你是在试图批评我或告诉我我不够好吗？”是的，因为批评可能是一个非常大的问题，不是吗？比如有人对你说关于塑造、改进、反思的事情，你知道，那可能，特别是如果你之前有过被批评或被羞辱、羞愧的问题，
then that can make it feel like a really fragile experience to go through. But sometimes hearing good things about yourself can be really discombobulating for people as well. I'm aware I've used the word discombobulating twice, but, you know, I'm going to roll with it. it. So I did an episode on receiving feedback and it was all about receiving negative feedback and that being tricky. But actually, yeah, sometimes hearing good things about yourself can move you to tears or can make you very defensive content. Or it just simply doesn't go in. I think that's something I've really seen. Like your Teflon. Yeah, particularly with performer people, it can be sort of like, well, that's the baseline. That's the benchmark.
那么这会让你觉得这是一个非常脆弱的经历。但有时听到关于自己的好话也会让人感到非常困惑。我知道我已经用了两次“困惑”（discombobulating）这个词，但是，你知道，我打算继续用下去。所以我做了一期关于接收反馈的节目，内容全是关于接收负面反馈以及那有多棘手。但实际上，是的，有时听到关于自己的好话会让你热泪盈眶，或者让你变得非常有防御性。或者它根本就没听进去。我认为这是我真正看到的东西。就像特氟龙一样。是的，特别是对于表演者型的人，这可能就像是，“嗯，那是基准。那是标准。”
so I should be getting that feedback. Cool, move on. And that means that there's this kind of hole sitting there for self-esteem where kind of all those lovely nuggets of good feedback just aren't landing and kind of creating a sense of confidence that feels really grounded, which can be really devastating quietly in its own way. It really can. And I guess I'll share a little bit about how I use feedback. So we can't always be extrinsically, externally motivated. We must be able to hopefully pull on threads that can self-soothe ourselves. But what I will do when I hear something or when I achieve something is I will almost pop it under my metaphorical belt and I'll think, right, okay, I'm going to mindfully file that away. I'm going to store that for a trickier day. And the first thing I ever did that with was my GCSE results. So that felt like, okay, here's a tangible thing that when I'm feeling like I'm struggling, I'm just going to pop that there and I'll be like, okay, all right.
所以我应该得到那样的反馈。酷，继续。这意味着自尊心那里有一个空洞，所有那些可爱的、好的反馈都没有落地，也没有创造出一种感觉非常扎实的自信，这在某种程度上可能是非常具有破坏性的。确实如此。我想分享一点我是如何使用反馈的。我们不能总是被外在动机所驱动。我们必须能够希望利用那些可以自我安抚的线索。但我听到某事或取得某项成就时，我会几乎把它塞进我隐喻的腰带里，我会想，好吧，好的，我要有意识地把它归档。我要把它存起来以备更棘手的一天使用。我第一次这样做是在我的 GCSE 成绩出来的时候。所以这感觉就像，好吧，这是一个有形的东西，当我感觉自己在挣扎时，我就会把它放在那里，我会想，好吧，没关系。
So you can't be that awful because you did get, you know, X, Y and Z. But people can begin to build up this bit of a toolkit using their internal, their external motivators, can't they, Kate? Have you got any strategies that might be really helpful for people as well, Kate? Absolutely. It was something I actually did when I was having a difficult time myself, but it was something I learnt. There's like this geeky kind of small sub-treatment for low self-esteem with a good evidence base called positive memory retraining. And it essentially involves identifying what the negative self-image is. And then it's written beautifully by these Dutch researchers.
所以你不可能那么糟糕，因为你确实得到了，你知道，X、Y 和 Z。但人们可以开始利用他们的内在和外在动机来建立这种工具包，不是吗，凯特？你还有什么对人们非常有帮助的策略吗，凯特？绝对有。这实际上是我自己在经历困难时期时做的事情，但这是我学到的。有一种针对低自尊的、有良好证据基础的、极客式的亚治疗方法，叫做“积极记忆重训练”（positive memory retraining）。它本质上涉及识别负面自我形象是什么。然后它被这些荷兰研究人员写得非常漂亮。
And it's kind of like, well, is that very fair? And is it sort of proper for you to have this belief of yourself without really, really investigating whether you are indeed boring or not? And the protocol entertains the idea that you could be boring. but actually you might have other redeeming qualities that so offset the boringness so it kind of doesn't matter which I thought was lovely. But in essence it gets you to identify what a sort of realistically grounded positive belief about yourself might be and then kind of pour in some evidence and there's imagery work. So you identify the word like I am capable and then you have different. memories that really strongly resonate with you about being capable.
这有点像，嗯，这公平吗？你对自己有这种信念，而不真正去调查你是否真的无聊，这合适吗？该方案提出了你可能很无聊的想法，但实际上你可能有其他弥补性的品质，抵消了无聊感，所以这其实并不重要，我觉得这很可爱。但本质上，它让你识别出一个关于你自己的、现实且扎实的积极信念，然后注入一些证据，还有意象工作。所以你识别出一个词，比如“我有能力”，然后你有不同的
You pair it with music and possibly even a power pose and you rehearse this memory, these memories and this phrase until you actually kind of beef yourself up. And at one point I actually, a strategy they suggest is going through evidence, anything from your school reports to leaving cards that people have sent you, birthday cards, whatever, and amassing this evidence. And it's a really, really lovely exercise to do. I even messaged a couple of friends and just got the most beautiful comments back from people. And when you see all this kind of mass of evidence together, you're like, wow, okay. Yeah, that negative belief isn't the whole story. So it's different from a lot of problem-focused approaches that we tend to work with in clinical psychology.
记忆，这些记忆强烈地引起了你关于“有能力”的共鸣。你把它与音乐甚至是一个“力量姿势”（power pose）配对，你排练这个记忆、这些记忆和这个短语，直到你真正地增强了自己。有一次我实际上，他们建议的一个策略是检查证据，从你的学校报告到人们寄给你的告别卡、生日卡，任何东西，并积累这些证据。这是一个非常非常可爱的练习。我甚至给几个朋友发了信息，得到了人们最美丽的评论。当你看到所有这些证据聚集在一起时，你会想，哇，好吧。是的，那个负面信念并不是全部。所以它不同于我们在临床心理学中倾向于使用的许多以问题为中心的方法。
But it's actually a really positive, rather lovely experience to do. so it's definitely a toolkit that I kind of use little sprinkles of in my work. That sounds so lovely. And I use a sort of hybrid of our, both of our approaches that on my phone, so I've got an iPhone, on my phone I will create a phone album called Smile File. And when someone sends me something or I see a review or, you know, something happens. Or, you know, my kids do something. I think I'll add that to the Smile file.
但这实际上是一个非常积极、相当可爱的体验。所以这绝对是我在工作中会撒一点点用的工具包。这听起来太可爱了。我使用了一种我们俩方法的混合体，在我的手机上，所以我有一部 iPhone，在我的手机上我会创建一个名为“微笑档案”（Smile File）的相册。当有人给我发东西，或者我看到评论，或者，你知道，发生了什么事。或者，你知道，我的孩子们做了什么。我想我会把它加到“微笑档案”里。
And then when I need a little bit of a boost, I go back to that. But I love the idea. Sometimes giving accents to things can be really helpful. So when I used to do sessions in the NHS for people, sometimes we would use different voices to kind of represent different characters because it really helps bring them to life. My children sometimes like me to just speaking in an Australian accent because I'm much more fun mum when I'm Australian.
然后当我需要一点提升时，我就回到那个档案。但我喜欢这个想法。有时给事物加上口音会非常有帮助。所以当我过去在 NHS 为人们做咨询时，有时我们会使用不同的声音来代表不同的角色，因为它真的有助于让它们栩栩如生。我的孩子们有时喜欢我用澳大利亚口音说话，因为当我是澳大利亚人时，我是个更有趣的妈妈。
But yeah, we used to kind of a blend of Russian, like, you know, different. different French accents. Like, I love that and it really helps you think, right, where's that coming from and is that still valid? And even the idea of being boring, sometimes people might be a bit boring, but we still love them for it because they're really passionate about what is they're talking about or we accept them for that. And like you said, we've got other things that we also really like about them. So the boringness isn't a deal breaker. Absolutely. Yes. There are many good questions. that I think sort of slightly sidelined in society at the moment, but being a reliable, honest,
但是是的，我们过去使用一种混合了俄罗斯口音，就像，你知道，不同的法国口音。就像，我喜欢那样，它真的能帮助你思考，好吧，那是从哪里来的，这还有效吗？即使是关于“无聊”的想法，有时人们可能有点无聊，但我们仍然因为他们对所谈论的事情充满热情而爱他们，或者我们因为这一点而接受他们。就像你说的，我们还有其他我们也非常喜欢他们的东西。所以无聊并不是一个交易破坏者。绝对是。是的。有很多好问题，
sort of good storytelling person, or perhaps not so good at storytelling, but telling your stories anyway, there's a lot to be said for that. Yeah, and when I was first started dating my husband, I really liked his consistency. I really liked that he would say that he would call me on a certain day. on a certain day at a certain time, and then he did it, Kate. And like, you know, some of the guys I dated, this was like radical. It was like, oh, gosh, wow, is this how life is supposed to operate? Like, because this guy does what he says.
我认为目前在社会中被稍微边缘化了，但作为一个可靠、诚实、好的讲故事的人，或者也许不那么擅长讲故事，但无论如何都在讲你的故事，这有很多可说之处。是的，当我刚开始和我的丈夫约会时，我真的很喜欢他的稳定性。我真的很喜欢他会说他会在某一天在某个时间给我打电话，然后他真的做了，凯特。而且就像，你知道，我约会过的一些男人，这简直是激进的。就像，哦，天哪，哇，生活本来应该是这样运作的吗？因为这个家伙说到做到。
Sometimes he does extra things as well, like, whew. And I think sometimes when it comes to dating, we can get used, I guess, from the earlier relational patterns, perhaps, of our own parenting or a previous partner's gone by. We can think that it's always going to be that way, or that we can't ask for more. And I know you've got a bit of a specialist interest in dating as well, haven't you, Kate?
有时他也会做额外的事情，比如，呼。而且我认为有时在约会时，我们可能会习惯，我想，从我们自己父母或过去伴侣的早期关系模式中。我们可能会认为它总是会那样，或者我们不能要求更多。而且我知道你对约会也有点专业兴趣，不是吗，凯特？
Yes, absolutely. I sort of went through my 30s, having finished a major relationship, kind of extremely confused about why I was making certain decisions and sort of what was going on. And so I've kind of worked backwards from me. there now having a very lovely partner and child to kind of produce the what I wish I'd had, which is a bit of a blend of psychology informed sort of stuff and also very, very practical ideas. And yes, the thing which got my goat when I was in this position is with attachment
是的，绝对。我度过了我的 30 多岁，结束了一段重要的关系，对为什么我做出某些决定以及发生了什么感到极其困惑。所以我有点从我这里倒推。现在有了非常可爱的伴侣和孩子，来制作我希望我当时拥有的东西，这有点像心理学知情的东西和非常非常实用的想法的混合体。而且是的，当我在这个位置时，让我感到恼火的是，按照我们通常谈论的依恋理论，它感觉有点像终身监禁。它有点像，哦，你有焦虑型依恋。是的。而且那并没有真正……哦，好吧，你总是会……而且所有这些评论，比如“水往低处流”，或者你遇到了你所处发展阶段的伴侣，它让你觉得，
theory as we typically talk about it, it feels like a bit of a life sentence. It's kind of like, Oh, you've got anxious attachment. Yeah. And that doesn't really, oh, well, you're always going, and sort of all these comments like, oh, water finds its own level, or kind of you meet the partner at the stage of development that you're at, and it kind of leaves you thinking,
嗯，我不想要那个。那我该怎么办？而且实际上，我认为当你开始融入更多实用的、类似 CBT 和图式疗法的想法时，你可以开始为人们分解它，这样他们就可以更快地发现事情并做些不同的事情。所以这就是我开始发展这种“清晰保护模式”想法的地方，它在约会中真的很有帮助，因为他们可以看到它，而且可以很快看到它。所以如果你考虑，比如一个“帮助者模式”，那是某人从童年起就有责任感，当某人需要帮助或脆弱时，挺身而出承担
well, I don't want that. So what do I do? And actually, I think when you start to blend in a bit more practical sort of CBT-ish schemarish ideas, you can start to break that down for people so that they can spot things sooner and do something different. So that's where I started to develop this idea of clear protective patterns and it really helps people in dating because they can see it and they can see it quickly. So if you think about, say, a helper pattern, that's someone where it's made sense from childhood to be responsible, to where someone is needy or vulnerable, to step forward and take
责任，那么实际上如果他们遇到那些大多数没有这种模式的人会说“哦，不，谢谢。你显然没有处于能够提供稳固关系的位置”的男人。那么他们可能会介入，成为那个人的一个非常好的支持，然后一年后想知道为什么他们的需求在关系中完全被排除在外，他们突然变得非常不快乐，但又非常非常依恋这个人。而如果你知道你有那种模式，那么你已经会想，哦，好吧，所以那不好。而且实际上，我经历的那些人对我不可用，只是因为我狭隘地关注这一类人，但外面可能有其他人如果我把它用作
responsibility, then actually if they're meeting men who most other people without that pattern would go, oh, no, thank you. You're clearly not in a position to give a sort of solid relationship. Then they might step in, be a really great support for that person, and then wonder sort of a year later why their needs are completely off the table in the relationship and they're suddenly very unhappy but very, very attached to this person. Whereas if you know that you've got that pattern, then already you're like, oh, okay, so that's not good. And actually, my experience that people aren't available to me is just because I've been narrowly focused on this lane of people, but there might be other people out there who would be available to me if I use that as an
自动折扣，继续前进。所以这就是为什么我实际上喜欢做约会咨询，因为你有更多的机会为某人创造一个完全不同的轨迹。是的，你可能比我的品味更高雅，但这让我想起了，我猜是《爱情盲选》（Love is Blind）、《一见钟情》（Married at First Sight）和《爱之岛》（Love Island）。人们经常会说，你知道，“纸面上你的类型是谁”，你知道，那是一个“令人反感”（ick），让我感到反感，你知道，“哦，那是一个红灯，那是，你知道，那是绿色行为”，所有这些。但实际上，是的，我认为有像你这样的人在场，你知道，帮助人们思考这个问题，并且不要认为某事是红色行为，而实际上它只是与你预期的不同，
auto discount, move on. So that's where actually I love working with dating because you've got much more opportunity to make a completely different trajectory for somebody. Yeah, you might be more highbrow than me in my viewing, but this is reminding me of I guess love is blind, married at first sight and, you know, Love Island. People will often say, you know, who's your type on paper, you know, that's a, that's an ick, gives me the ick, you know, oh, that's a red light, that's, you know, that's green behavior, like all of this. But actually, yeah, I think having a, having someone like you on board, you know, to help people think this through and to not not think that something's a red behavior when actually it's just different than what you've expected,
只要它在心理上或身体上没有害处，也许有一些容忍度。是的，我的意思是，去年夏天似乎有一种趋势，我想是关于，是“公主待遇”吗，我想是，它有点像你需要期望你的男人像对待公主一样对待你。如果他们不这样做，那么他们就不值得。而且所有这些事情，都有某种真相，因为，是的，你需要保持一种你期望从某人那里得到的行为标准，特别是在开始时，因为那是他们最有动力的时候，对吧？但实际上，公主待遇，你知道，我看到了这些糟糕的 TikTok 短片，男人们只是走进来，给这些女孩展示钻石项链。在一段关系的开始，如果你得到的是每天送花，
so long as it's not harmful psychologically or physically, maybe there's some tolerance there. Yeah, I mean there was some kind of trend, I think it was last summer, which was about, was it the princess treatment, I think it was, where it's kind of like you need to expect your man to treat you like a princess. And if they're not doing that, then they are not worth it. And like all these things, there's kind of a kind of truth to it because, yes, you need to sort of hold a standard of behaviour that you're expecting from somebody, and especially at the beginning, because that's when they're most motivated, right? But actually, princess treatment, you know, I saw these awful TikTok reels where guys were just coming in and presenting like diamond necklaces to these girls. And at the start of a relationship, if what you're getting is sort of flowers every day,
被开门，每天被打电话，不，每半天，不，每小时，大量的消息，比如，我们去度假吧。哦，我想我爱你，我们结婚吧。实际上那不好，那是“爱情轰炸”（love bombing）。那是你正在接触的人有非常强烈的“连接者模式”的标志。而在实际了解彼此和亲密关系变得真实的那一刻，那将会炸毁你的脸，因为下面没有一个坚实的基础，比如，这个人是谁？我们有共同的价值观吗？我们有
being held the door open, called every day, no, every half day, no, every hour, loads of messages, sort of, let's go away. Oh, I think I love you, let's get married. actually that's not good, that's love bombing. And that is a sign of someone that you're getting involved with who's got a really intense connector pattern. And that is going to blow up in your face at the point where actual knowledge of each other and intimacy becomes real, because there isn't a firm foundation underneath of actually, who is this person? Do we have values in common? Do we have
适合彼此的生活方式吗？如果他们失业了，或者他们的父母生病了，他们能维持这种行为吗？所以这就是为什么这些约会趋势有时真的真的让我恼火，你需要一个更稳定的基准。是的，我听到了。我也不想成为任何人的公主。你知道，也许我会成为我自己的女王。
a lifestyle that fits with each other? And can they sustain this behaviour if they lose their job? or if their parent gets sick. So that's where actually these kind of dating trends really, really get my goat sometimes and you need a steadier benchmark. Yeah, I hear you. I don't want to be anyone's princess either. You know, maybe I'll be my own queen.
但我只是不想要那个。那可能会让我感到反感。这说明了很多关于我的事情。但我想要的是被尊重，被认为是能干和自信的，你知道，在身边感觉很好。但也能够容忍我的一时糊涂，你知道，因为我不是一个完美的人。而且要，你知道，就是那种，是的，那种“无论我的行为在任何时候是否可爱，我都被爱”的想法。而且我不需要担心，你知道，因为我在工作中度过了棘手的一天并把它发泄在
But I just wouldn't want that. Like that would probably give me the ear. It says a lot about me. But what I do want is to be respected. and to be thought of as capable and confident and, you know, nice to have around. But also to be able to tolerate my rubbish a moment, you know, because I am not a perfect person. And to, you know, it's that kind of, yeah, that idea of I'm loved whether I, whether my behaviour is lovable at all times. And that I don't need to worry about, you know, having, you know, being dumped because I have a tricky day at work and take it out on.
我丈夫身上而被甩，你知道，这真的很重要。所以我喜欢这种好奇、冷静、灵活、心理学知情的方法，而且我认为，是的，我希望这在人们听或看的时候真的能引起共鸣。我认为还有别的话要说，那就是有一种非常不责备的方式来看待我正在为后来让我非常心烦的动力机制做出什么贡献。所以如果你考虑一种动力机制，也许你更像是一个讨好者或帮助者，这两件事都是真的，你可能在关系早期做的事情是不去关注你自己的需求，不去说出来，因为它感觉没那么重要。谁在乎是中餐还是意餐？我不在乎。但实际上，如果那是你正在创造的模式
my husband you know it's it's really important so I love this kind of curious calm flexible psychologically informed approach and I think yeah I hope this is really resonating for people as they as they listen or they watch I think there's something else to say which is there's a very non-blaming way of looking at what contribution am i making to dynamics that later get me really upset. And so if you think about a dynamic where perhaps you're more of a pleaser or a helper, both of these things ring true, what you might do quite early on in relationships is not tune into your own needs, not speak up because it doesn't feel that important. Who cares if it's Chinese or Italian? I don't mind. But actually, if that is the pattern that you're creating
从一开始，你甚至没有对某人满足你需求的小机会进行压力测试，以后突然扭转关系并展示你的脆弱、展示你有什么真实需求会变得困难得多。所以你最终可能会处于一种在关系中非常怨恨的位置，因为，你知道，你的需求和偏好
from the beginning, you're not even stress testing tiny sort of opportunities for someone. to meet your needs, it becomes a lot harder later on to suddenly turn the relationship around and sort of show your vulnerability, show what real needs you've got. And so you can end up in a position where you're very resentful in a relationship because sort of your needs and preferences
没有被考虑在内，但实际上有一条路你可以从一开始就走，它会把你带到一个不同的地方，在那里你实际上已经把你的需求放在了位置上，你已经陈述了小的愿望和偏好，并且你已经分享了小的脆弱时刻。而这种事情对于那些在关系变得亲密且需要一些脆弱性时基本上会感到反感的“保护者”来说尤为重要。所以是的，这不仅仅是关于发现别人的红旗。
aren't taken into account, but there's actually a path you can walk from the beginning that leads you to a different place where actually you have put your needs in place, you have stated small desires and preferences and you've shared small moments of vulnerability. And that kind of thing is particularly important for protectors who can get the ick basically as soon as the relationship becomes intimate and some vulnerability is required. So yes, it's not just about spotting red flags in other people.
还有一些思考的元素，我们在这里跳什么舞？这个人可能是哪种类型的人？而且实际上，我可能如何助长了一种也不服务于我的模式？我能做些什么来测试我们的关系是否足够灵活，足以成为我的一段好关系，或者我实际上应该走开。是的，而且那种“哦，我不在乎，你知道，任何东西，你选，你知道，那很好”的想法。一段时间后可能会让人筋疲力尽，因为你会想，嗯，我不想一直当老板。我希望你是你自己命运的守护者。所以当我的妈妈在我家时，我会说，哦，你要喝杯茶吗？她说，是的，但我不要
There's also elements of thinking, what dance are we doing here? What type of person might this person be? And actually, how might I be feeding into a pattern that's not serving me either? And what could I do to test whether our relationship is flexible enough to be a good one for me or whether I actually should be walking? away. Yeah, and that idea of, oh, I don't mind, you know, anything, you choose, you know, that's fine. It kind of can be exhausting after a while because you think, well, I don't want to be the boss all the time. I'd like you to be the keeper of your own destiny. So when my mum's around my house and I'll say, oh, do you want a cup of tea? And she goes, yeah, but I won't have
红茶，你知道，草本茶会很棒。我会说，好的，我有大约 50 种，你要哪一种？哦，随便，你选。我会说，嗯，不，我希望你选。就像，给你。你选，你可以选，因为你可以喜欢你生活中的事物。而且我可能会给你我真正讨厌的那一种。为什么你应该拥有，你知道，别人的“剩饭剩菜”？我们真的想赋予人们权力去思考，嗯，我的价值观是什么？我的喜好是什么？我的厌恶是什么？也许我可以要求满足我自己的需求。所以也许如果我觉得这样做对我来说不合适，也许这是一个旧模式，或者我周围的人不允许我展示我自己的那一面。而那都是
black tea, you know, a herbal one will be great. And I'll be like, okay, I've got about 50, so which one do you want? Oh, anything, you choose. I'm like, well, no, I want you to choose. Like, here you go. You choose, you get to pick because you get to like the things in your life. And I might give you the one that I really hate. Why should you have, you know, someone else's sloppy seconds? We really want to empower people to think, well, what are my values? What are my likes? What are my dislikes? And maybe it's okay for me to ask to have my own needs met. So maybe if I feel like that's not okay for me to do, maybe this is an older pattern, or maybe I'm around people that are not allowing me to show that side of myself. And that's all
有趣的信息。是的，绝对。而且不是为了推销我的方法，但我认为我的方法中有一个我相当喜欢、我认为相当聪明的一个方面是，从我自己的经验来看，我认为有，当你思考过去对你不奏效的关系时，你会从治疗中得到真正好的东西。你可以开始发现那些不会服务于你、你想避免的模式。但你从治疗中真正得不到的是，好吧，那么我实际上在向什么方向前进？一段好的关系是什么样的？而且我认为这个关键点有点像我们之前谈论的积极记忆重训练类型的东西。就像，好吧，如果不是那个，那是什么？
interesting information. Yes, definitely. And not to not to plug my approach, but an aspect of it that I rather like that I think is rather clever is from my own experience, I think there was, You get really good stuff out of therapy when you think about relationships in the past that haven't worked for you. You can start to spot the patterns which aren't going to serve you that you want to avoid. But what you don't really get from therapy is, okay, well, then what am I actually moving towards? What does a good relationship look like? And I think this key plank is a bit like the positive memory retraining type stuff we talked about before. It's like, okay, if it's not that, what is it?
这就是你可以思考的地方，嗯，我的核心价值观是什么？我可能会真正享受什么样的关系？所以对有些人来说，那可能是，你知道，一年两次环游世界，拥有一个非常非常忙碌的社交生活和成吨的孩子。而对其他人来说，那可能是一个安静的海边房子，只有你们两个人每天早上手牵手走在沙滩上。但如果你没有一种感觉、许可，去真正地去你自己的，你知道，咨询你自己并思考什么是可能的，
And that's where you can be thinking, well, what are my core values? What kind of relationship might I really enjoy? So for some people, that might be, you know, traveling the world twice a year and having a really, really busy social life and sort of tons of children. And for other people, that might be a quiet sort of seaside house with just the two of you walking along the beach every morning holding hands. But if you don't have a sense, permission, to sort of just really go to your own sort of consult yourself and think what's possible
然后找到一种方法把它编织进你的约会过程中，这样你就可以寻找某人是否会与此兼容，那么你真正陷入的只是回避，而当你试图约会时，这也会非常令人瘫痪，特别是在以后的生活中。是的，我喜欢那个。嗯，为了我丈夫的 50 岁生日，我们去了康沃尔一个非常非常可爱的地方，就在悬崖顶上，有非常大的开放式窗户，它有自己的桑拿房，非常特别。它有点像我们只能去住三晚。就像没有周末，只有三晚最低限度。我们确实做了那样的事情。
and then find a way to sort of weave that into your dating process so that you can look for is someone are going to be compatible with that or not then all you're really stuck with is avoidance and that's also can be quite paralyzing when you're trying to date especially in later life yeah i love that um for my husband's 50th we went down to a very very lovely place in cornwall that was just right on the cliff top, really big open windows, it had its own sauna, it was very special. It was kind of we could only go for three nights. Like there was no weekends, it was only three nights minimum. And we did exactly that.
我们只是花时间在一起散步、吃早餐，你知道，去吃馅饼。而且所有这些都是如此好的东西。但因为那是我们俩都想要的，因为我们俩都有忙碌的工作，我们俩都有孩子。而且，你知道，我们在这个周末出去了，没有足球训练。但我们只是能够闲逛，
We just spent time together going on walks, having breakfast, you know, going to have pasties. And it was all such good stuff. But because that's what we both wanted, because we've both got busy jobs, we've both got children. And, you know, we were away over this weekend where we didn't have football practice. But we were just able to lounge around. and read books, but also be companionable to do our own thing. So he wanted to take some photos.
阅读书籍，但也能够陪伴彼此，做我们自己的事情。所以他想拍一些照片。
I wanted to sit around read books, eat chocolate tiffing, and listen to Nora Jones. Like those two things have to be okay if that's, you know, you have to be able to leave room for that. But that said, you know, when we're talking about all these red flags and kind of communications from other relationships, it is okay to use relationships and previous relationships to work out what is a no-go? For me, there are a couple of absolute no-goes that I just would not entertain in my current relationship because I've learned that from past relationships and it's like a zero tolerance approach for that particular thing because that did not make me feel psychologically safe. So we're not saying there can be no red flags. You're allowed to learn from your experiences,
我想坐着看书、吃巧克力松糕、听诺拉·琼斯的歌。如果那是你想要的，你得给自己留出空间，这两者是可以共存的。但话虽如此，当我们谈论所有这些危险信号以及来自其他关系的沟通时，利用之前的关系来确定什么是不可触碰的底线是可以的。对我来说，有几条绝对的底线，在目前的关系中我是绝对不会妥协的，因为我从过去的关系中吸取了教训，对于那件事我采取零容忍态度，因为它让我感到心理上不安全。所以我们并不是说不能有任何危险信号。你可以从自己的经历中学习，
but just check that whatever rule you've got is functional. Absolutely. So what I think is that you need a very small amount of deal breakers that are very grounded and based in your either general bad things or your personal catnip that is going to take you in the wrong direction. And I definitely identified some and then still with that written down, found myself in a couple more relationships. I was like, oh no, I've done it again.
但要检查你所设定的规则是否实用。当然。所以我认为你需要极少数的、非常扎实的交易破坏者（底线），这些底线要么基于普遍的坏事，要么基于你个人的“猫薄荷”（致命吸引力），它们会把你引向错误的方向。我确实确定了一些，但即使写下来了，我还是发现自己又陷入了几段关系。我当时想，噢不，我又犯同样的错误了。
But I think what's important when you're making your list of deal breakers is that those things are psychologically grounded and what's safe for you. Because what you can find is that people, you know, have almost a wish list of needs to be so tall with such background and this amount of money and all that kind of stuff. And those things, you know, there is sort of evidence that some level of social and intellectual compatibility will definitely be a good thing for the relationship. but actually there's loads of different ways people can be compatible. Someone doesn't have to look like what you thought they would look like
但我认为在制定底线清单时，重要的是这些事情要基于心理基础，以及什么对你来说是安全的。因为你会发现，人们几乎有一份愿望清单，要求对方身高多少、背景如何、有多少钱等等。而对于这些事情，确实有证据表明一定程度的社会和智力兼容性对关系肯定有好处。但实际上，人们兼容的方式有很多种。一个人不需要长得像你想象的那样，
to be really good for you. So I think the deal breakers out of all the things are the most important. And then if you've got a sense of your values and the kind of lifestyle that works for you, that's where you can just be gently comparing quite a wide variety of people as to whether they will fit with that. Oh, I love that. The catnip, that really made me smile
才能真正适合你。所以我认为在所有事情中，底线是最重要的。如果你对自己的价值观和适合你的生活方式有了一定的了解，那么你就可以轻松地比较各种各样的人，看看他们是否符合这些要求。噢，我喜欢这个。那个“猫薄荷”的比喻真的让我笑了，
because it just made me think, yes, yes, I did have a lot of, lot of catnip going on. And those ideas, oh, you know, I like tall, I like blue eyes. I like, you know, dark hair. You know, like I like a certain build. I've never dated anyone like my husband who is blondeish. I always kind of went, my catnip was probably the main character energy. My husband is a drummer, you know, so behind the scenes, like, you know, keeping the pace of everything. And just very much not what I would have thought I wanted on paper. And interestingly, if had been on a dating website. I might have even seen the pictures of the drums have been like, no, no swipe left. But when we met in a club with a sticky floor and I saw him in person, he just really, you know,
因为它让我想起，是的，是的，我确实有很多很多“猫薄荷”式的吸引。那些想法，噢，你知道，我喜欢高个子，我喜欢蓝眼睛。我喜欢深色头发。我喜欢某种体型。我从来没有和像我丈夫这样的人约会过，他是金发。我总是，我的“猫薄荷”可能是那种主角光环。我丈夫是个鼓手，你知道，在幕后，保持节奏。这完全不是我纸面上认为我想要的。有趣的是，如果是在约会网站上，我可能看到鼓的照片就会想，不，不，向左滑。但当我们在一个地板粘糊糊的俱乐部见面，我亲眼见到他时，他真的，你知道，
I went up to him and I was a bit drunk and I spoke to him. And I think remotely I wouldn't have done that. It's led to us being together since 2010. So yeah, like, maybe don't discount things. Don't discount people too soon, but know that. some messages, those hard and fast boundaries are important. But yeah, beware of that catnip. That is really, really good advice, Kate. Where can people learn more about you and your work? They can go to my website, www.org.com.
我走过去找他，当时我喝了点酒，我就跟他说话了。我想如果是在远程，我可能不会那样做。这让我们从2010年一直在一起。所以，是的，也许不要太快否定事物。不要太快否定人，但要知道，有些信息，那些坚定不移的界限很重要。但是，是的，要小心那种“猫薄荷”。凯特，这真是非常非常好的建议。人们可以在哪里了解更多关于你和你工作的信息？他们可以访问我的网站，www.org.com。
And that's got details about my private practice and also the Find Your Person program. Thank you so much. I'll make sure all of that is in the show notes. For anyone who is listening, I will just spell, Sherritt. So it's S-H-E-R-R-A-D-T. Thanks so much for your time, Kate. I've so enjoyed speaking with you. You too. It's been an absolute pleasure. Thank you. It's been a lovely conversation. It really has. Thanks so much. Thank you so much to my guest, Dr Kate
上面有关于我的私人诊所和“找到你的人”项目的详细信息。非常感谢。我会确保所有这些都在节目说明中。对于正在收听的任何人，我来拼写一下，Sherritt。是S-H-E-R-R-A-D-T。非常感谢你的时间，凯特。和你交谈非常愉快。你也是。这绝对是一种荣幸。谢谢。这是一次愉快的谈话。确实如此。非常感谢。非常感谢我的嘉宾，凯特·谢罗特博士。
Sherrott. Please do go and follow her on LinkedIn and Instagram, where she is Dr. Kate. psychologist. You might well be listening to this podcast for a variety of reasons, but if it's because you are wanting to get your career moving into clinical psychology or another one of the psychology professions, I think you'll really love all the formulating, the interview practice, the preparation, all of the reflections, all the brilliant growth that is available to you in the aspiring psychologist membership, which you can join from just £30 a month with no. minimum term. And if you like the idea of one-to-one time with me, if you join for either six months upfront or one year upfront, you get free time with me too. So check out
请务必在LinkedIn和Instagram上关注她，她的账号是Dr. Kate. psychologist。你可能因为各种原因在听这个播客，但如果是因为你想让你的职业生涯进入临床心理学或其他心理学专业，我想你会非常喜欢“有抱负的心理学家会员”中提供的所有构思、面试练习、准备工作、所有反思以及所有出色的成长机会，你只需每月30英镑即可加入，没有最低期限。如果你喜欢和我一对一交流的想法，如果你预付六个月或一年，你还可以获得我的免费时间。所以请查看
the details on the screen or the details in the show notes. If you like a little peek behind the lens, a little peek behind the curtain about what life is like as a clinical psychologist and the way that I think about my work, the world, my family, myself and others, I think you'll really enjoy diving in and having a free trial of Inner Work, which is an exclusive subscriber-only podcast series. You can get a free three-day trial on Apple Podcasts. You can also get a free trial on Patreon. You can even get a free minute of every episode on Patreon as well.
屏幕上的详细信息或节目说明中的详细信息。如果你想一窥临床心理学家的生活，以及我如何思考我的工作、世界、家人、自己和他人，我想你会非常喜欢尝试一下“内在工作”的免费试用，这是一个独家订阅者专享的播客系列。你可以在Apple Podcasts上获得三天的免费试用。你也可以在Patreon上获得免费试用。你甚至可以在Patreon上获得每一集的免费一分钟试听。
I'm Dr. Marianne Trent Everywhere. Come and follow me on my social media. If you love these episodes, please do take screenshots. Please do share them to your stories. me in your comments, tag me in your posts. I really do love hearing from you. If you have episode ideas that you think I should cover, come and let me know about those two. Or if you like to come and be a guest on the podcast for psychology actually, let me know, get in touch. Might just surprise you. The answer might be yes. Just a quick one before we dive into today's
我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。请在我的社交媒体上关注我。如果你喜欢这些剧集，请务必截图。请务必分享到你的故事中。在评论中提到我，在帖子中标记我。我真的很喜欢收到你们的消息。如果你有认为我应该涵盖的剧集想法，也请告诉我。或者如果你想来做客播客，谈谈心理学，请告诉我，联系我。可能会让你惊喜。答案可能是肯定的。在进入今天的话题之前，先简单说一下，
episode. If you're in private practice, you might know the slightly awkward dance of actually getting paid. The I'll send you a bank transfer later that can often turn into sending chasing emails three weeks on. Well, this episode is brought to you by write-up and their new tap to pay app might just sort that out for you. It turns your existing smartphone into a card reader. Your client finishes their session, taps their card or phone on yours, payment lands, receipt sent. No card machine to buy, no clunky terminal, no awkward. And because it's built into write-up, the payment links straight to the client's invoice and notes. So your admin actually stays joined up. Write-up is the practice management platform
如果你在私人诊所工作，你可能知道实际收款时那种略显尴尬的舞蹈。“我稍后给你转账”往往会变成三周后发送催款邮件。好吧，这一集是由Write-up带来的，他们新的“点击支付”应用程序可能正好能为你解决这个问题。它将你现有的智能手机变成读卡器。你的客户结束疗程，在你的手机上轻触他们的卡或手机，付款到账，收据发送。无需购买刷卡机，没有笨重的终端，没有尴尬。而且因为它内置在Write-up中，付款直接链接到客户的发票和笔记。所以你的行政工作实际上保持了连贯。Write-up是实践管理平台，
built in the UK for UK practitioners. Have a look at write-up.com. That's W-R-I-T-E-U-P-P.com. Use code Marianne 30 for 30 days free and 30% off your first six months and see if it makes your week that little bit lighter with much better cash flow. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在英国为英国从业者打造。看看write-up.com。即W-R-I-T-E-U-P-P.com。使用代码Marianne 30可获得30天免费试用，前六个月可享7折优惠，看看它是否能让你的工作周轻松一点，现金流更好。此剧集尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。